مدينه نيكابول جنوب اوكرانيا اقرب المدن
الى محطه زفر النوويه
لا صوت هنا يعلو على صوت تحذيرات السلطات
من وقوع كارثه نوويه
مخاوف بدات اثارها في نفوس سكان المدينه
دعم فتن بالطبع اشعر بالهلع فوق كل هذا
الخوف لا املك مقومات الحياه اعيش وكانني
لا اعيش
لسدادات جديه لهذه الكارثه المحتمله على
الرغم من كل التحذيرات الحكوميه على الاقل
هذا ما تشي به النوافذ والابواب المشرعه
على عكس توصيه السلطات باحكام اغلاقها
ويبدو ان للناس اولويات اخرى
الماء العنصر الاهم الغائب عن المدينه
اذ يعاني الاهالي منذ اشهر غياب الماء
الصالح للشرب
معاناه تعكس مظهرا اخر من اثار الحرب
المستمره
القصف المتواصل كذلك زاد من مشاق الحياه
وتحول القسم القريب من النهر في المدينه
الى احياء خاليه من اي مظاهر للحياه لا
تستبعد السلطات قيام الروس باحداث اي
تفجير هناك
وترى في ان ما حدث فيك خوفكا اشاره على
ذلك
مبينه حجم المساحه التي ستتاثر بشكل كبير
ندرب الناس على كيفيه التصرف عند الكارثه
لكن الممارسه تختلف عن التطبيق ثلث مساحه
المنطقه سيتضرر بشكل كبير جدا افضل ما
نستطيع فعله هو الاجلاء
القسم البعيد عن المحطه من المدينه يبدو
الحال فيه افضل من سواه هنا لا تبدو على
الناس علامات الانشغال بهذه الكارثه
المفترضه
اذ صرفهم عن ذلك الانشغال بتدبر امورهم
اليوميه
لطالما كانت هذه المحطه مبعث فخر
للاوكرانيين فضلا عن كونها مصدرا مهما
للطاقه اليوم تتحول هذه المحطه الى اكبر
مصدر تهديد للبلاد يعد بتكرار كارثه
عاشوها قبل اربعين عاما عمر الحاج الجزيره
من مدينه نيكوبول المقابله لمحطه النوويه